and Jill Wiesenthal co-host of would you  miss the church I'm looking at today is  the shanghai composite but i'm looking  at it in a slightly different way so  last night it got clobbered the stock  market was down like eight and a half  percent but check this out this is a  chart of the year-over-year change in  the shanghai composite so basically how  much it's changed since last year it  still looked like seventy percent from  last year despite the fact that I got  clobbered last night and had been  getting slammed in the weeks previous so  the regulators and the government there  are in this huge monumental battle to  keep the stock market up people are  sitting on major gains if the stock  market the stock market has plenty of  room to fall still if things go haywire  that's my chart of the damn Jill  Wiesenthal watch what do you miss for 24  30  you